a thriller that's relatable to the
pandemic age a dazzling tollywood film
that mixes fact and fiction a disturbing
hamlet-inspired drama there is more to
the big screen than just these here are
the best movies of 2022 so far
you've heard the term elevated horror
now get acquainted with its close cousin
quiet scifi
after yang is a character drama centered
around a father who suffers an unusual
loss the loss has to do with yang yang
is a lifelike android programmed to
connect the father's adopted daughter to
her chinese heritage however suddenly
yang shuts down while the father seeks
out a way to repair yang he and his
family are forced to ponder yang's place
in their lives and explore yang's own
inner life that he chose to conceal from
them don't be misled by that pg rating
after yang is a tender patient and
elegant film for grownups that ruminates
on themes of memory intimacy and
identity
belle follows a talented teenage
songwriter suzu who's been unable to
raise her voice in song since the tragic
death of her mother but when she logs
into the futuristic social media
platform you suzu transforms into belle
a spellbinding songstress who becomes a
global sensation overnight as suzu
attempts to reconcile the two parts of
herself she becomes fascinated by an
infamous online prize fighter with a
monstrous virtual avatar though
originally released in japan and on the
festival circuit in 2021 the critically
acclaimed anime musical bell finally
arrived in us theaters in january 2022
it's nominally an adaptation of the
classic fairy tale beauty and the beast
for the social media age but belle
brings far more to the table than just
the familiar beats of its source
material bell is part timeless and part
bleeding edge contemporary as
exemplified by its two distinct but
equally beautiful art styles there's the
painterly traditional animation to
represent the real world and eye-popping
cel-shaded cgi to represent the virtual
reality of the internet
mix one part college buddy movie with
one part thriller and stir in a shot of
social commentary to give it some bite
and you've got emergency
a pair of college seniors plan to be the
first black students to complete a
legendary bar crawl on their campus but
their plans are interrupted when they
find an unconscious white girl sick with
alcohol poisoning in their living room
certain that calling the authorities
will only get them arrested or worse
they embark on an increasingly
complicated quest to drive her to the
hospital themselves a spoonful of stoner
comedy helps the medicine go down as
emergency highlights the way systemic
racism increases the danger and
difficulty of life for black americans
think about it statistically
how many people actually get shot by the
cops it's like really really unlikely
right
the kovid 19 era has produced a number
of locked room feature films they're
films produced with a minimal cast in an
isolated location to reduce the risks
and costs of working during a pandemic
good luck to you leo grand stands out
among this accidental genre it's
essentially a two-person play set almost
entirely in a london hotel room here
emma thompson plays a retired ethics
teacher who hires a young sex worker to
help her rebound from decades of
unfulfilling sex with her late husband
it's an argument in support of legalized
sex work but the heady controversial
conversation never weighs down this
charming dialogue driven comedy
who would have guessed that the first
honest-to-goodness critical darling of
2022 would be jackass forever the
long-awaited fourth installment of the
film series based on the mtv prank show
of the same name sees johnny knoxville
stevo and the gang once again punishing
their bodies with elaborate pranks and
dares the twist this time they're
middle-aged the key to this film's
critical success is its total sincerity
despite the increased risk to their
health knoxville and company carry on
performing dangerous disgusting bits why
it's simply because they love making
each other laugh and to them nothing is
funnier now they get to share their
legacy with a new generation of
comedians who grew up watching them hit
each other's genitals and saying someday
that's going to be me
kimmy is a thriller that's extremely
relatable to the moments of 2022 zoe
kravitz plays angela a programmer whose
job it is to manually review garbled or
misunderstood communications between an
alexa style electronic assistant called
kimmy and its users when she stumbles
across an audio recording of a heinous
crime angela must try to get the
evidence into the right hands without
tipping off its perpetrators but there's
an added complication it's the middle of
the covid19 pandemic and angela is
severely agoraphobic kimi utilizes the
unique stresses of the present day from
the anxiety of being constantly
surveilled to the social and economic to
malt inflamed by the pandemic in doing
so we have a short sweet hour and a half
of intrigue and action
debuting at sundance and hitting
theaters and streaming later in 2022
resurrection is a white knuckle
psychological horror film in which star
rebecca hall delivers one of the year's
first great performances hall portrays
margaret a businesswoman and single
parent who seems in total control of her
life until a mysterious man from her
past resurfaces and sends her spiraling
into all-consuming panic what is it that
makes his mere presence so terrifying we
are absolutely not telling you need to
see this one for yourself rebecca hall
and tim roth sell the film's bizarre and
disgusting twists with such conviction
that they can stick with you long after
you finish watching
in 1996 director wes craven and
screenwriter kevin williamson ushered in
a new era of horror movies with scream
in which a group of teens are hunted by
a mysterious killer who is obsessed with
slasher movies each scream sequel has
commented on the nature of horror
sequels and the changing landscape of
horror cinema this fifth entry tackles
the contemporary trend of the recoil in
which legacy characters pass the torch
to a new generation but as always scream
isn't just about dorky inside jokes for
xenophiles it's also a thrilling horror
whodunit in its own right with scares
and chuckles in equal measure scream can
be enjoyed as either a jumping on point
or a satisfying conclusion to one of
horror's most consistent franchises
the streets of gotham city have never
been grittier than in the batman a new
interpretation of dc's most popular
superhero despite being yet another
reboot that takes the character back to
basics as a lone crime fighter chasing
gangsters and serial killers the batman
still feels distinct it's different from
both christopher nolan's nuts and bolts
realism and tim burton's dark whimsy
more than any previous batman film it's
a detective story closer to a 1970s
neo-noir than a modern action
blockbuster within the film's ambitious
three-hour run time you'll find
memorable performances gorgeous
photography and the most in-depth
exploration of the title character ever
to hit the big screen don't let me hurt
you you better watch it
based on the popular 19th century french
stage play cyrano is a musical romance
starring peter dinklage as a warrior
poet who's hopelessly in love with his
oldest friend roxanne this latest twist
on the classic romance features original
songs written by members of the indie
rock band the national it also showcases
dinklage's untapped potential as a
leading man both during the film's
comedic first hour and it's heavier
dramatic second half
evelyn wang is an exhausted and
unfulfilled laundromat owner who's just
trying to get her taxes done when she's
suddenly recruited to fight in an
interdimensional war to save the
multiverse evelyn will have to learn how
to verse jump she'll have to tap into
the feelings memories and skills of her
alternate selves all of whom have done
more with their lives than she has
everything everywhere all at once is
uproariously funny visually dazzling and
deeply moving michelle yeo delivers an
oscar-worthy lead performance and that's
without even factoring in her multiple
off-the-wall fight scenes that demand
both great technical skill and comedic
timing
8th grader may lee awakens one morning
to discover she has transformed into a
giant red panda just as every woman in
her family has for generations may's
panda form emerges whenever she
experiences strong emotions and her
mother ming expects her to reign it in
like she did but what if mae likes being
an excitable furry monster
turning red is a joyful celebration of
friendship family and how the awkward
process of growing up complicates both
it must be so difficult keeping that
unruly beast at bay
director michael bay's maximalist style
of action filmmaking has rarely produced
a better product than ambulance
ambulance is a pulse-pounding heist
thriller that's basically a
feature-length car chase it's the story
of two brothers one a career criminal
the other a desperate marine veteran
attempting to escape a deadly bank
robbery in a stolen ambulance with a
brave emt and a badly wounded police
officer as their hostages bae infuses
ambulance with a killer combination of
old and new school production techniques
there's practical automotive action and
also a metric ton of pyrotechnics
perching cameras on the noses of
high-speed stunt drones that give the
audience a first person view of their
daring dives and barrel rolls the
screenplay is not exactly shakespearean
but when it comes to dizzying
blockbuster fun look no further
as sidhunt adlaka of indie wire puts it
rr is a dazzling work of historical
fiction emphasis on the fiction rrr is
essentially a superhero epic based on
two real indian revolutionaries of the
1920s who likely never actually met it's
a violent thrilling heartfelt and
gleefully over-the-top tollywood action
musical blockbuster its song and dance
number not two not two has gone mega
viral online and it teases only a small
fraction of the bombastic excitement of
its battle scenes rrr is no hollow
spectacle beyond its anti-imperialist
political message
rrr also boasts one of the most
unreservedly sincere bromances in modern
cinema it's a three-hour film that
energizes rather than exhausts its
audience by the time the credits roll
you'll feel like you could punch a hole
through the moon
the bad guys follows the exploits of a
gang of famous thieves who attempt to
rehabilitate their public image
pretending to reform while actually
planning their biggest crime yet based
on a series of graphic novels for young
readers by aaron blaby the art style of
the bad guys embraces its 2d ink and
paper origins this results in a
distinctive and fun visual aesthetic
that looks like nothing dreamworks has
produced before looper's alistair rider
calls it the studio's best effort since
the first how to train your dragon
sequel it balances out its lowbrow kid's
humor with a surprisingly good send up
of hip heist films like ocean's 11 and
reservoir dogs
in this very modern thriller a young
woman exhausted by the online dating
scene takes a chance on a charming
stranger who she meets at the grocery
store he seems too good to be true and
of course he is but nothing could have
prepared her for the gruesome reality of
his intentions fresh is a grim bloody
tale with a sick sense of humor a
cutting criticism of the way men
commodify women and their bodies it's
not a subtle film and its politics are
sometimes transparent to the point of
pandering but its message has value
the film as a whole offers far more
gasps than it does groans
from celebrated director robert eggers
comes this unflinchingly brutal
historical fantasy based on the ancient
viking epic that inspired shakespeare's
hamlet the dethroned prince amleth will
stop at nothing to exact vengeance
against the uncle who slew his father
and kidnapped his mother but will his
quest leave him more beast than man the
northman is as visually stunning as it
is disturbing a meticulous and
unsanitized portrait of the grim and
miserable past in amla's blood-soaked
world cruelty is the only currency and
deaths are always paid with interest
i am i'm not a bad wolf
the premise of the lost city is rather
similar to the 1984 adventure film
romancing the stone in which a romance
novelist finds herself on a real-life
treasure hunt through the jungle with a
roguish hunk at her side the lost city
is as much a parody of this idea as it
is homage sandra bullock plays a
best-selling author of erotic adventure
novels who's washed up and embarrassed
of her success instead of a devilish
indiana jones type she's paired up with
the sweet but dimwitted model played by
channing tatum from the cover of her
books while the lost city doesn't
approach the level of craft on display
in romancing the stone it's the sort of
charming low stakes adventure flick we
wish would hit the big screen more often
is sonic the hedgehog 2 a cinematic
masterpiece on par with the likes of
paddington 2
no not quite but is it a comic action
adventure that's an absolute blast to
watch it is indeed the super fast blue
hedgehog of sega fame once again fights
the diabolical dr robotnik once again we
see jim carrey demonstrate that he's
just as much a cartoon as any talking
animal that the effects department can
render but now the cast of computer
generated characters has expanded
bringing the series closer to the purely
animated kids film franchise it probably
should have been in the first place
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
new movies are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one